the flash season 3 finale delivered some
twists and turns an uncertain fate for
our hero and a sneaky Easter egg that
likely reveals the big bad - season 4
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and there's just so much to discuss
after that season 3 finale so in this
video I'm going to break down some of
the best Easter eggs from the final
episode finish line and the rest of
season 3 plus I'll be explaining the
tease of a season fours big villain just
before I get stuck in a quick reminder
that my arrow verse giveaway is running
on this video and for a chance to win
any of these cool Funko pops be sure to
subscribe and leave a comment about the
season finale season sorry easter eggs
all your predictions for season 4 now
spoiler warning for you if you're not
caught up yet on season 3 and if you
want a spoiler free video instead check
out my 10 awesome facts you probably
didn't know about the flash by tapping
up here so let's start with that
shocking ending where Barry sacrifices
himself for the good of Central City by
entering the Speed Force the title of
the finale finish line was already
hinting that Barry would be reaching an
end of sorts and visually the shot of
him walking into the Speed Force which
is personified as his mother Nora feels
like Anna March the comic book cover of
the flash volume 1 issue 350 but this
episode is a bittersweet spin on that
comic book story as in that issue the
flash is finally reunited with the love
of his life iris whereas in the show of
course he has to leave iris behind after
spending the whole season trying to save
her just before he leaves iris says
central city needs the flash and Barry
responds by saying they'll have one and
embracing Wally now in the comics Wally
West took on the mantle of the flash
after Barry Allen's death so is the TV
show hinting at that as a likely future
I don't think the series would be the
same without grant gustin's flash and in
the 2024 newspaper headline that we saw
in the finale we still see a picture of
gustin's flash on the cover suggesting
we will be getting Grant Gustin back at
some points the real question then is
how long will it be in season 4 before
what's left of team flash venture into
the Speed Force or the plan to break
Barry out or before Barry himself
discover the way to return an excuse the
team flash to rescue Barry from the
Speed Force next season all for him to
break out himself would be that they
need his
to defeat the show's new Big Bad and in
the scene with Salvatore and berry at
STAR Labs there's a clever easter egg
for who we should expect that baddie to
be when saboteur says to Barry this is
where we came up with a cerebral
inhibitor to use against Avvo and then
he adds you haven't got there yet DeVoe
was also named dropped earlier this
season by the villain abracadabra in
episode 18 and these two mentions are a
big tease for our future flash foe in
the comics Clifford tuvo is a lawyer
turned criminal and is the first villain
who took on the alias of the thinker
DeVoe makes you to the thinking cap
device that gives him mind control and
other telekinetic abilities given that /
producer Andrew Kreisberg already
confirmed that after three seasons of
speedster villains the big bad for
season four would not be a speedster
DeVoe is a very likely candidate
speaking of villains with also a cool
Easter egg and tease for another DC
Comics villain - I wonder if we'll see
in a future season of the flash the
show's penultimate episode dropped a
very cool Wonder Woman Easter Egg when
Barry and Captain Cold broke into Argus
and walked past a holding cell labeled
cheetah who's in major Wonder Woman
villain there's been several distinct
incarnations of cheetah over the years
in the comics with her first appearances
back in 1943 when she was co-created by
William Moulton Marston who of course
also gave us the character of Wonder
Woman by the way if you're a Wonder
Woman fan check out my video with some
of the best Wonder Woman Easter eggs in
season two of Supergirl and I'll also be
making some videos soon on the new
Wonder Woman movie as well the title of
the episode where we get the cheetah T's
is Infantino Street which is Anna Marsh
the remarkable comic book artist carmine
infantino
you reinvented the flash in 1956 when he
co-created a character of Barry Allen
among the many other characters
Infantino created a Wally West
solovar who appeared in the episode
attack on gorilla City and the
villainous abracadabra who I mentioned
earlier okay let's look at some more of
the best season 3 Easter eggs the titles
are the first two episodes of this
season of flashpoint and paradox which
is a sly wink - the animated film
justice league the flashpoint paradox
which is an adaptation of the 2011 comic
book storyline flashpoint which season
Tori the flash also draws on and the
scene where Barry battles the rival in
the season premiere is a clear callback
to the show's pilot
episode which also featured tornadoes
barry racing around them a weather
wizard named drop and joe west shooting
berries adversary' and the apple
obviously hasn't fallen far from the
tree in the West family because the way
IRA shoots avatar to save Barry in this
season's finale echoes away Joe
repeatedly saves Barry in the same
manner when criminal Sam Scudder and
Rosalind Dillon are transformed into the
metahumans mirror master and the top
there's a lovely hat tip to the
co-creator of their comic book
counterpart writer John Broome at the
building where the transformation takes
place belongs to broom industries and
when the top robs the bank along with
her metahuman partner in crime the
colors of the outfit she's wearing or a
nod to the green and yellow costume worn
by the comic book character she's based
on Rosco Dillon Plus well serves as a
mirror master on his earth who uses a
mirror gun and is called Evan McCullough
and that's the same as a second mirror
master character who exists in the
comics in the Flash's alien invasion
crossover episode when team flash bring
together Team arrow legends and
Supergirl to face the dominators they
all gather in a STAR Labs hangar that
looks just like the Hall of Justice
which was the super heroes headquarters
in the 1970s animated TV series
Superfriends and that popular animated
show gets another big shout out in the
flash and Supergirl musical crossover
were burying Korra sing a duet called
Superfriends which is written by Rachel
bloom the star and creator of another
superb CW show crazy ex-girlfriend the
song also includes lots of Flash related
puns just like in the comics a nod to
how Berry's messed up the timeline and
some light-hearted mocking of Korra's
cousin Superman the prolific and
influential comic-book writer Gardner
Fox who co-created a character the flash
in 1940 gets a subtle tribute on this
poster when the trickster commit the
robbery on earth three it's Fox Bank
given the Barry Allen visit earth 3 to
speak to Jay Garrick in this episode
it's especially fitting that Gordon of
Fox received the name check here as Fox
not only created the first flash aka Jay
Garrick but also his 1961 story flash of
two worlds which brought together Jay
Garrick and Barry Allen who
habited parallel worlds and launched the
DC Multiverse and did you also notice
that Fox Bank is located on Nelson
Street which could be a possible
reference to another of Gardiner Fox's
creations Kent Nelson aka dr. fate when
Cisco suits up to battle the earth 19
bounty hunter [ __ ] and again later
killer frost the costume he worth is a
callback to the outfit his comic book
namesake wore in the new 52 vibe comics
including its color and the quilted
textured effect on it
when saris memory is accidentally wiped
in episode 21 he can't even remember his
own name but when team flash
tell him he's called boss for the new
Henry Allen or Barrie for short because
impulse is for them to call him Bart
instead which is a delightful Easter Egg
to the comics were boss Allen as a
speedster who at different times takes
on the mantle of Kid Flash and the flash
and his grandparents just happened to be
Barry Allen and iris West by the way
this isn't the first time that Bart
Allen has been named checked in the air
over during the arrow flash crossover in
2014 the Quentin Lance got Barry's name
wrong and called him Bart Allen now what
do you want to see happen in seasons 4
of the flash and what were your favorite
Easter eggs in season 3 plus what are
your thoughts on the season finale be
sure to leave a comment and subscribe
for a chance to win one of these cool
Funko pops which I'm giving away on this
flash videos as well as on my Supergirl
Easter Egg video and my upcoming arrow
season 5 Easter Egg video too if you
enjoyed this video do please like and
share it and check out more of my Easter
egg and DC videos by clicking or tapping
the screen here thanks for watching and
see you next time yippee JRuby lovers